yeah like we're also gonna enable people
to watch like videos like streaming yeah
through the browser you'll be able to
watch like you know Netflix or whatever
you know YouTube if it's if the cars
parked and it connected to Wi-Fi so if
you're like say out of supercharger
station and you want to watch something
you can watch it on the screen in the
car but the general principle is like
how do we eat you know what can we do to
make the the car the most fun possible
and and like what would a car what other
cars just don't have you know and so it
seems like well you know if there's like
just you just parked somewhere waiting
for somebody to finish an appointment or
if you don't on a road trip be pretty
cool if you just like you know go to the
car screen and at play some like some
fun game and anyways exploring like you
know how do we make it as fun as
possible
you can already play all the old Atari
games or almost all the old Atari games
on the car and we hooked it up so you I
can connect Xbox or ps4 controller and
like actually have some a pretty good
control feedback and then we have like
genius moves like the fart app my finest
work okay and and you know it's like
there's you can actually make you can
make the fart sound like it's coming
from any seat the funniest Easter Egg
that one then actually the names of the
farts yeah there's the Falcon Heavy is
one of them yeah and I know you got
we've got some clips right of what the
yeah some clips of some upcoming games
in the car and you know it's just made
to be like hey what are some cool games
that people might like to play and
depending upon how much people play them
will you know Adam to the like higher up
higher on the list or maybe put it into
sort of an archive that you can tap to
download because the screen was not
originally meant as a game player so
it's just it doesn't actually have
much storage that but so it won't have
that many games on it at any one time
but it will just be like okay what do
people really enjoy playing and that
might be a good way to past time so
alright let's take a look at games on
Tesla
[Music]
[Music]
you
all right cut that and that's not all we
got second one too right yeah got a
racing game that you it's you need to
play single player or two player
all right game to check it out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the steering wheel I wasn't prepared for
that that's pretty cool yeah I mean if
you have a racing game and you have a
steering wheel you tight like gas brake
will that work - or it's not yeah really
yeah
well I think we actually we've got the
the brake is is wired in and I think
we'll probably have maybe the scroll
wheel for the gas pedal just so that guy
so he doesn't accidentally sipping on
the brake if you're stationary is not a
problem right that's amazing well it's
so cool that you're doing that inside
the cars I want to ask you guys about
the idea you know you're both certainly
known for a ton of incredible successes
in your careers and you know you said
before you on that sometimes you know
you're you're really only innovating if
you're kind of ready to fail or have
failure you know along the way shows
that you are pushing renovation Todd
you've been through kind of you know
quite a year was sort of you know fallen
76 and you've been pretty public about
you know sort of the challenge is there
you guys maybe riff a little bit on that
about sort of you know the the push for
innovation and how you know sometimes
failure is part of that journey well
usually when you get to you know take
gaming that the things that it's the
first time you see and they're new they
become successful but you got there by
trying big new things and we're gonna
keep doing that and other game makers do
that and I think it's good that the
audiences are welcoming to that they're
gonna they're gonna try it out and and
support us as we as we go through that
process to figure out hey what's gonna
make this tick and we had you know
obviously had our ups and downs with
fallout 76 but that our fans are
incredible and have really stuck with us
and now it's really turned into one of
the best online communities that we've
we've ever seen it's fantastic news I
mean through your career I'm sure you've
seen that too right words there been
projects that you know take time to
evolve but that's part of what part of
what it takes I guess right it's kind of
having that vision and pushing for it
sure I mean if you're gonna try
something innovative then then you're in
explored territories so that odds that
something will go wrong we're pretty
high if you know it's only if you try to
something that is already well
understood that there's a little little
chance of failure but then it will not
be interesting or innovative so you know
for sure unchartered territory will
result in failures necessarily otherwise
you know trying hard enough
speaking of uncharted territory you
mentioned star fields which we we
haven't seen much on Todd besides you
know one little trailer last year but
obviously space is gonna be a part of
that I'm curious you know I know how
much you can tell us about the game but
it you know I should ask what can you
tell us about Stan I do not have a clip
no sorry it's everyone needs to be
patient on that but I can't say it's
like how we approach it so it feels it's
a game but it still has an authenticity
- okay this could happen you know we
talked like what kind of few will do the
ships use like we're using helium-3
which we can debate whether that's a
good power source for spaceships or how
do the physics work in space and gravity
and those kind of things and that's
where you get into we have to gamify it
some so that it's not as punishing as
actual space travel but that it feels
like hey traveling in space in our game
is still let's say it's like flight in
the 40 like it's dangerous it's still
dangerous to go and explore but even
though lots of people do it yeah spaces
bar that's the thing like definitely cut
that short
it's like light-years man even at light
speed that's pretty far so I mean I
think like if you wanted like a normal
based on known physics like antimatter
drive would be the best but that's the
limit to you to light speed which is a
long time yeah how to have some kind of
warp drive otherwise this is you're
gonna be stuck in one star system so I
mean just are sick so I feel like we're
in some freaking video game you know
I'm like why is it like Juris possible
to get to Mars why the Stars so far away
it's just what I'd do in fires in the
painting doing a video game for those
stars little points light don't worry
about it you can't see details are real
far stuff that you know you doing with
SpaceX how is are you looking at that
when you're building star field and I
don't know how far in the future it said
or sort of how that's look it's further
in the future but I like that you know
going back to that risking failure and
stuff I think I mean honestly the world
needs more people like Elon who say I'm
not sure how that works I'm gonna try
this a different way and a lot of people
will doubt that whether it's going to
space in that way or self-driving cars
but that's I'm very passionate about
those things and as it comes to what's
happening at SpaceX it's you know what
are the limits of the physics of like
the new engines or things like that
where you know talking to Elon how far
could this go in current reality and
then how do we how would we move beyond
that in a fictional way yeah yeah Jay
talked a bit about that obviously you
know you're dealing with the reality of
today but you know something futuristic
like what Todd is doing does that get
you excited to sort of think about like
you know what is where space travel
going to go and how can something like
Todd's world simulate that or explore
that even further off yeah I think xif
eye movies video games orbit you know
you and really I think people spend a
lot more time on video games and movies
these days it can be pretty inspiring
until provoking about what's the future
that we want to water some like
impossible sounding technologies that
maybe could work somehow like this
conceivably a way to do warp drive but
it's like it's such esoteric super out
on the edge physics because technically
you cannot go faster than the speed of
light but but space can travel faster
than the speed of light that's what's
meant by wolf drive but the amount of
energy you need to warp spaces
unbelievably gigantic so you know you'd
have like be converting matter to energy
at a rate that is we cannot conceive
really you know it can't be like
something the wool if we just compute
won't convert one Jupiter per second to
energy then prom salt like that's a lot
and there's not many Jupiter's and there
might be a bit of radiation around that
so like there are things like like
technically the universe did expand
faster than the speed of light that's
that's a that's why we can see light
from all these super distant stars like
yeah so it's it's kind of pretty well
that's base expanded fast than speed of
light so sure like figure out some
strange breakthroughs and you know come
to grips better with like this is dark
matter especially which seems like
something's fishy going on there and it
has bad branding yeah yeah exactly the
universe is mostly dark energy and dark
matter according to current physics but
you know this kind of plug in the you've
plug them in the equations and they sort
of work and like yeah it's just not a
good explanation ever you can find the
dark matter but I sort of figure ika if
this is a video game and somebody had a
bug in there like overall dynamics a
physics simulator and that's like oh no
we're gonna figure out some way for
these minions in here to leave that
there in reality so insert not matter
the idea of you know a game as a
simulation sort of you know predicting
things wherever I mean obviously it's
entertainment on some level but there
are games where it's like it is more of
a simulation or maybe not but sure it's
is there is their value there in that
and sort of in kind of you know testing
things and exploring ideas inside of a
game world yeah actually it is
we have a wholesome team that tries to
create a photorealistic
world and we're trapping photorealistic
about like actually the most boring
things like skid marks on the road and
and like concrete curbs shadows faded
lines on this like the reason
self-driving is hard is because you have
all these corner cases and things what
the road should be a certain way that it
isn't like there should be fading
painted lines but there aren't painted
lines and they or they took the paint
lines away and then there's a skid mark
that's offset from the painted line so
that will cause the car if it just
listens to the lines to crash into stuff
if you if you clearly painted lines and
could count on them self-driving would
be trivial like just I have Pisa cake
but but the world is just filled with
all these things that are not the way
they're supposed to be and then the the
real trip trick with the self-driving at
driving AI is to figure out what what is
the where should I be on this road that
has no painted lines or what lines been
painted wrong and it's got you know skid
marks and scratches and road work and
all sorts of things that are unexpected
that's that's this that's a really hard
part otherwise be child's play
so yeah that's we do a lot of a lot of
sim at Tesla and we have found I get
great correlations like does the car
draw it drive off the cliff and some yes
just drive off the corner Ally well we
got close I think you said it once I
like it's not the lines it's it's
looking for drivable space is more
important than the markings in real life
because that's how your minds actually
working yeah you know lame you can't
there's someone there it's more drivable
space that's the problem
yeah absolutely so actually recently
found that we need we have like pretty
good recognition of lines and and and
what's what's technically drivable space
but but we actually need what is road
and as opposed to what is like what is
what is the most probably the road as
opposed to drivable space and what is
and then
a whole subset on curbs we're really
into curbs right now some curbs are
really subtle and somebody should care
about somebody shouldn't care about and
sometimes you go into a driveway and
it's got a little curb and then the
cause like a curb can't go over that you
know or like upgrading a drive space
going through like a neighborhood and
then everyone's driveway is drive space
technically true but you don't it could
go through everyone's driveway it's not
good I think I was gonna say you think
about like that a lot of that stuff
started video game wise like image
processing and things like that and AI
and what they're doing there is I you
know people look at technology now they
always underestimate how fast technology
moves in the present day they don't cast
back you look at things but I think the
self-driving and what's happening now is
gonna fundamentally change the world in
ways that people can't even expect and
you think about our children might not
even learn to drive because the cars
will all be driving themselves around or
how it affects cityscapes or parking
lots alcohol consumption there's just
like all these studies that are going
likes if you look at like what are the
best self-driving stocks alcohol
companies and more games to play to
companies like video games a drove
computing technology especially GPUs
massively it's like that's a really
thick I don't think you needed GPU for
was to have the game look better and so
those massive resources put into
rendering games to be more realistic and
then those same GPUs ended up being very
useful for neural nets and gave a huge
boost to AI so it's sort of video games
better graphics to AI and and and then
that that same thing is sort of quite
quite key to self-driving know you have
open AI don't ask Todd a bit about AI
and game III and sort of where games are
going right so you know you obviously
have RPGs that are simulated worlds and
people have done things with you know
emergent behavior and other characters
radiant I things like that but
can you talk about maybe sort of where
games are going in the next you think in
the next you know five 10 plus years in
terms of the AI and the simulation and
what's going to sort of happen there I
think that's the part of gaming that's
gonna make the biggest jump I think the
graphic fidelity most people react to
instantly they're looking at a
screenshot or a video but there's
there's some laws of diminishing returns
there's things start to look better and
better and better and better but as far
as how a game feels the other characters
in the AI you know I think a lot of
people including us have struggled with
how do you make that feel real and now
that you can move some of that
processing to the cloud and that's other
things I think that's the part where
it's going to get significantly better
over the next generation that means what
characters know you better or I mean
what you know things that you you did in
a more realistic manner the more
reactive to what you're doing or the
situation around them you know the curb
problem is this that you get that in a
video game all the time you know we get
to a point where these games become more
sort of indistinguishable from reality
and I'm curious about you know what what
do you think sort of you know where do
you think this goes ultimately is these
games continue to improve graphics get
better but then the simulation gets
better do we reach this sort of you know
singularity at this point where sort of
you know the game in the world is the
same thing the simulation is imagine if
we were to reach such a situation that
would be crazy
[Laughter]
we see those like these creatures in the
game saying imagine can you imagine if
there was a simulation like you're in a
simulation it's simulations all the way
down the simulation in the simulation in
the simulation seems likely
I mean well if you assume any rate of
improvement of video games at all then
one or two things is gonna happen
civilization will end or games will be
so realistic you can't tell difference
between them in reality
i postulate is this this sound correct
or not correct yeah yeah I mean it was a
good thing but it's just we could be
somebody's like video game right now
right chef who's avatar you know but you
know when you look at games in the fitt
the games you play now I mean what are
the things you want to see in games that
don't happen right now they're anything
like when you play a game you're like I
wish it did this or I wish I you know
you're obviously thinking about you know
lots of things but when you play games
are you satisfied or the things that
frustrated you about games what do you
want to see games do the future I should
say yeah you working on a game - no I
mean like I don't know and I I mean like
to be honest when you look at you know
the stuff that you play now I guess you
talked about Todd's game so I'm curious
kind of you know wider spectrum your
kids play games you play games like what
are you you know what excites you like
what games are you looking forward to
what are you what have you played
recently like what there are lot of
games out there what does it take for a
game to attract your interest sure I
mean last couple years actually haven't
played a lot of games because it's been
super intense work situation so just
work see the kids for a bit and then yep
like I'm not enough sleep so that's been
a situation for a couple years so just
haven't had much time to pay a games lot
you know the probably actually the
last game that I played a lot which was
probably fallout 4 so I was good one and
he was like I'm done that's good I like
the theme and we're actually that really
was what we said to have our pickup
truck as I kind of like a cyberpunk
themed pickup truck that the unveiling
hopefully in the summer okay yeah it
looks weird
really yeah it's like normal okay yeah
directly but the theme in the game a
little bit it was inspired about the
game afterwards it's just something
we've been working on for a while yeah
but I just sort of act a general idea
and yeah so it's it's sort of you know
like sort of you know sort of it has a
slight Blade Runner feel to it and so it
definitely does it doesn't look like a
normal car looks like it should not be
on the roads and it will a matter of a
movie or something but so I you know
weren't appeal to everyone but it'll be
something that's different and you know
and we you know probably feels I think I
would buy it yeah you know I think like
if I'm working something and like my
experience is like it's really hard to
and like if you try to figure out what
others love but you don't love it it's
really hard to make that great so when
you work on something if you fall in
love with it that's that's a good sign
and then don't worry about if others do
if you do others will imagine saying how
you probably feel about making games to
top an idea that you have to love and
play it absolutely and it's not just me
it's the whole team there's a game
Studios who these are the kind of things
we would line up at midnight to go play
and buy
and that's what you know drives your
passion to do it you have to be your own
kind of taste maker day in and day out
if you're always focused testing it with
someone like this you you often miss the
mark yeah one thing about is online play
and you've got these you know a lot in
the news recently a lot about the
Starling satellites and the idea of you
know internet around the world low
latency and gaming could be I think one
of the sort of beneficiaries of this can
you maybe talk a bit about that project
and how it will tie in to potentially
gaming sure we actually one of the
design criteria for Starling is to have
latency in it for the initial
constellation on the order of 20
milliseconds of blow which is important
for a real time gaming and then the
later sort of second generation third
generation constellations are aiming for
sub 10 milliseconds so this would be
really great for any kind of real time
gaming yeah and it is the across the
world you'll be able to sort of access
that yeah anyone on earth Wow that's you
know what's exciting we look at you know
these cloud platforms streaming
something like that I mean Todd when you
from a designer perspective that must
open up so many possibilities I think
about you know where games are gonna go
in the future right I think it's about
democratizing who can play right now
there's still a lot of barriers to I
want to play that game okay I got to buy
the head of this I have to be somewhere
so having that be that you can approach
it like any other entertainment like
okay I listen to music it's quite you
don't think about it there's so many
ways to do it and that's where you know
games need to be where it's ubiquitous
it's not just in our part of the world
where people are connected well it's
other parts of the world that are
growing and these you know billions of
gamers who are coming into the scene who
don't have the access that we we take
for granted all right won't you maybe a
couple audience Q&A a little AMA here if
you'll raise your hand we'll get a mic
to you we can have a couple questions
for these guys this is a rare
opportunity hello how you doing good
we're streaming on Twitch right now by
the way chance at which hello I had a
question about the possibility of living
in a simulation when you think about
like all the quirks
every individual personality how things
work on a cellular level like the
universe everything doesn't it start to
see more far-fetched when you see how
intricate and individual things are okay
what do you do about that the idea thank
you I appreciate it
next question let's say you go over here
yep hi big fan Charles where your tongue
yeah I you know I talk you say hey hey
um thanks for coming thanks guys you on
so if we want to get some mores that's
taking a long time to get astronauts out
there what kind of entertainment plan do
you have I mean hopefully they're gonna
be able to play games on their way to
Mars what do you think about that yeah
absolutely
sure LAN party in space mine is simple
you on musk how much do I have to beg to
get a selfie with you sure all right
next next question back there
yeah the red shirt on how do I sign up
to test out your neural net program well
I just put this USB C port in your head
and
don't worry it'll be fine
might sting a little all right question
for Todd Howard I live in the West in
Rockville Maryland are you looking for
any interns by chance
go to our website there's a lot of job
postings here alright maybe just a
couple more yeah sure right over there
yeah my kid hey hey you on wow this is
crazy yeah so right now I'm trying to
build like a tokenized game economy for
gamers so my question is for to karma
points and on behalf of our simulation
overlords can you sign my cyberpunk hat
sure we'll get it up here forever all
right two and a half comma points all
right Mike debt hair glasses car more
Disney real I'm just wondering with all
the noise you deal with there's lots of
craziness how do you stay focused
because I can't imagine yeah it's insane
his premise was you do stay focused yeah
pretty focused it's so many things man
um
I feel like the levels keep it yeah
we'll keep ratchet can we just turn that
difficulty level down one notch that
would be really helpful the difficulty
[Laughter]
of you actually you mentioned failures
before what's the actual biggest failure
that you that you've gone through to get
to where you are
[Applause]
who goes first
that's a tricky question it's funny it's
an interview question I ask people right
and I don't respond if you were in the
military have the best failures they
meaning like they crash satellites and
tanks and things like that
I do not have a good answer for that I
mean we blew up three rockets in the
beginning that was bad okay we actually
only had enough money originally only I
basically took all money I made from
PayPal put her into SpaceX to creating
SpaceX Tesla and SolarCity and initially
figured I'd just keep half of it and
then I spend the other half on these
crazy adventures that would probably
fail and then unfortunately they needed
a little money so so you have to give
them all the money and then I didn't
have a house or ad to borrow money for
rent that was I was pretty difficult I
was back in 2008 and there were managed
to scrape enough spare parts together to
do a fourth launch at SpaceX and that
worked and if it had not worked his face
ex would have died and probably would
have lacked the credibility to raise the
remaining money for Tesla and we
wouldn't be here today
well maybe like not this ending
I guess for me I'd have to be this
similar the games we made in the period
after Daggerfall we made a bunch of
games that just they didn't land and the
company was gonna go out of business and
we got a lifeline and then like hey
let's do this game morrowind this is
what we should do and that that's save
the company all right one more question
last question you want to up top up
there that's you go through the lights I
know they're way up there alright yeah
maybe the hand way up there yeah yeah
y'all let your question
actually what we launch all the time we
do kind of 20 to 30 launches a year most
of them from Cape Canaveral some are
from Vandenberg here in California and
in order for for people to really see a
launch like that like that super crazy
visible kind of looked looked like a you
know nuclear alien invasion from North
Korea okay some of the YouTube videos
are pretty funny yeah number one Lions
went fullest there was broke down a
9-1-1 system so we were actually I would
freshman year was happening so it was
like a rocket launch but the the next
thing is probably the Falcon Heavy
launch at the end of this month
that's at out of Cape Canaveral so
that's got the two side versus they come
back and land this will be the the most
we're pushing the envelope a little bit
with with Falcon Heavy so it's more side
load from the boosters and you know
higher dynamic pressure for really
meaning like the ascent percent air
pressure will be higher it's just like
pushing harder through the air so
that'll be an exciting won't to see if
you're at the Cape and then you know
hopefully later this year we should be
doing test flights of starship out of
South Texas and the end on the Cape this
is a crazy looking vehicle
all right well I think we're
unfortunately out of time while those
keep going on you know and thank you so
much for coming to e3 being a part of
this this is so cool to have you here
Scott Howard thank you doing this
once-in-a-lifetime sodomy launch thanks
everyone
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]